HE HAS GOT IT, BUT HE WASN'TBUT,
AWAY BY FORSBERG AS P P THAT RI.
A PILEUP IN FRONT.
A LONG SHOT THROWN INHINK THIRDT
COULD PROBABLY PLAY SECOND
PAIRING.
>> Gord: IN MUCH.
TKACHUK KNOCKS IT DOWN.
THAT PASS FACE
BRAN
TAKEN HARD BY NOT-- AWAY FROM Z.
JUST ON SPE OF THE NET WHERE
IT JUST STAYS IN MISERABLE
GAUDETTE MOVES IN.
FOR
TOUCH PLAY RIGHT IN FRONT BY CAM
KONECNY DROPS IT
MASK AND HANGS ON TO IT.
>> Jamie: WHAT A GREAT TYPE OF
DURESS FARTHER UP IN THE
NORRIS IN TIMESAND TKACHUK.
FIVE-ON-FOUR NOW ON THE POWER
PLAY.
CONNOR BROWN FLIPS IT BACK
WALLET.
HE CAN BUY YOU THAT BACK TO Van
RIEMSDYK.
CHIPPED ON GOAL AND A GREAT SAV.
25 SECONDS TO GO IN THE POWER
PLAY.
THAT PASS KNOCKED AWAY BY ENNIS.
YANDLE KEPT IT ALIVE. THIS
EMPTY-NET GOAL DOESN'T HAPPEN I.
KONECNY DROPS THAT BACK
STANDING OVATION FOR HIM.
GOALTENDER HAS GONE TO WORK
HERE.
GETS KICKED